be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books throughout the
1920s del publications served as the
industry standard on print media led by
a syndicated series of newspaper strips
called famous funnies these publications
were the go-to source for comedy satire
and adventure but a new age was emerging
one which would force del publications
out of the limelight as a competitor
emerged with a flagship character that
would change print media forever
by 1952 the success of Superman a
Superboy was undeniable the Man of Steel
had captured the imagination of millions
and his comic stood on shelves around
the country
conversely Superboy had provided fans
with a life of Clark Kent between his
arrival on earth and the time he became
Superman however the popularity of
superheroes was rapidly fading to be
replaced by science fiction comics and
invaders from outer space attempting to
keep up with the changing times and
revitalized interest in superheroes
under the direction of DC editor Julius
Schwartz and writer Gardner Fox best
known for creating characters like the
Green Lantern Alan Scott the flash Jay
Garrick and the Justice League
predecessor the Justice Society of
America DC effectively rebooted their
continuity for the very first time
bringing it into the Golden Age starting
the Silver Age and by extension
expanding on the world and capabilities
of Superman with the United States in
the midst of the Cold War with the
Soviet Union following the end of World
War two under the Eisenhower
administration the idea of space
exploration was rapidly coming to be a
reality while man would not land on the
moon until 1969 under the presidency of
Richard Nixon because space travel was
as much an ingrained part of science
fiction as it was a legitimate
possibility the Silver Age powers of
Superman grew to reflect these
technological advancements and included
traveling to the depths of space as well
as massive expansions to his host of
abilities including super-hearing
SuperSpeed and super-strength however
for many fans there seemed to be no
explanation as to how these abilities
were so much more enhanced than they
were during a school in age counterpart
I so to answer this question
DC introduced two concepts the first was
the multiverse and the second was the
Yellow Sun with a Superman of Superboy
titles coming under the control of
legendary editor Mort Weisinger in 1957
as part of DC's attempt to relaunch
their characters and provide fresh
backstories Weisinger delegated a number
of changes to the Superman mythos and in
doing so established much of the content
that exists today the task of expanding
on the mythos was both easy and
difficult because Superman was so
popular like the great gold rush of
18-49 DC found itself in undated with
respected writers and artists looking to
make a name for themselves by receiving
their moment in the spotlight on the
other hand Superman fans guarded their
hero with jealous eyes and were avidly
against anyone making changes that
deviated too far from the original
content
looking to find a balance by appealing
to do fans and appeasing old fans for
early stories stated that Superman's
powers were tied directly to his
physiology in addition to Krypton's
gravity in relation to earth and where
Superman issued number 53 introduced
jor-el as the father of Superman in
issue number 146 which served as part of
DC's Silver Age retelling of the origins
for their various characters Weisinger
world these elements over and introduced
Krypton's red Sun as a reason for not
only why Krypton's didn't have powers on
their own planet but more so than that
explained the basis behind Superman's
new abilities as it was explained the
gravity of Krypton was several times
more intense than Earth and so when
Superman arrived the difference in
gravity allow for both super-strength
and flight in addition to this the
ultraviolet rays admitted by Earth's
Yellow Sun hardened Superman's skin
making it impenetrable to Earth's
weapons as well as enhancing his five
senses allowing him to achieve
extraordinary feats during the same year
a long-awaited team-up took place
between Batman and Superman spearheaded
by Edmund Hamilton the father of science
fiction and a writer for some of
Superman and Batman's best stories in
the late golden and early silver ages
the team-up between the two only served
to push their popularity to greater
heights as the original superhero
Superman stood atop the pantheon with
incredible strength and best abilities
but in contrast Batman was a normal
human with incredible wealth and
extraordinary physical training who
represented the power of human ingenuity
combining both characters and Superman
issue number 76 which featured a story
the saw the duo's attempt to stop a
criminal escaping with stolen diamonds
many comic historians consider this to
be one of the most important stories of
the Silver Age as this team-up served to
confirm that the superheroes of DC
Comics existed in a shared universe and
opened the door for friendship between
Batman and Superman as well as laying
the foundations for the introduction of
the Justice League in 1956
continuing to expand on Superman in this
place within DC in 1954 and 1958 at the
direction of Weisinger writer otto
bender created two stories titled
Superman's pal Jimmy Olsen and
Superman's girlfriend Lois Lane and were
to focus on the Man of Steel supporting
cast without side tracking from his main
stories because Superman was so popular
and by extension fans were clamoring for
most anything that expanded on his
publications both series were extremely
successful with Lois Lane solo series
selling just below Superman and Superboy
at the peak of its popularity however in
addition to the questions regarding
Superman's increased abilities between
the end of the Golden Age and the start
of the Silver Age questions also remain
involving the characters of flash and
Green Lantern because the Silver Age saw
the removal of Jay Garrick and Alan
Scott as a respective characters and
replaced with Barry Allen and Hal Jordan
without an explanation
in 1961 DC lost the story called the
flash of two worlds which served to
establish the multiverse and stating
that the versions of Superman and others
who appeared between the dawn of DC
Comics in 1938 up to the retelling of
their origins in the 1950s existed in a
separate universe called earth 2 with
the current versions existing in a
reality called earth 1 in addition to
this with the Justice League established
in 1956 by Gardner Fox albeit with only
occasional appearances by Superman once
again under the expansive direction of
Mort Weisinger writer Gary Coleman
introduced the fortress of solitude with
Action Comics issue number 241 initially
appearing without an explanation of how
it was built the fortress of solitude
was designed by Superman as a place of
Solace and a way to keep elements of his
Kryptonian heritage but also as a
tribute to the most important
individuals in his life originally
accessible by unlocking it was a giant
key that can only be lifted by those
with incredible strength the fortress of
solitude contained rooms dedicated to
various villains including Lex Luthor
and metallo but also friends like Lois
Lane Jimmy Olsen and Batman and so with
the Silver Age basis for Superman
established and well received by fans
and because the reception of Superboy
meant that the public was open to new
versions of Superman DC looked to expand
on the Man of Steel's role in their
lineup as well as tap into the
demographic of women and young girls by
creating a female version of Superman
that wouldn't hand her his romance with
Lois Lane and
which serve as a support role to fight
alongside both Superman and Superboy
created in 1958 by Otto bender
supergirls introduction actually came
out of several experiments involving a
female counterpart to Superman
like the Lois Lane super woman of Action
Comics issue number 60 in 1943 the
version depicted as Superman number 123
came as an experiment by DC to gauge fan
reaction to a legitimate version of
Superman who was the woman it created by
Jimmy Olsen after discovering a totem
the granted three wishes the events also
came with a compelling story centering
on Lois Lane as the main love interest
of Superman Otto bender sought to build
speculation on the possibility that Lois
Lane was being replaced and an effort to
drive controversy among fans and in turn
drive interest in supergirls
introduction as a story saw both
Superman and Supergirl fighting together
it was also relatively short and that
Superman discovered a bridge washed out
he was able to save it and discover that
the entire scenario was a trap set up by
unknown criminals looking to kill
Superman by exposing him to green
kryptonite while he tried to save the
Train with Supergirl jumping in to save
Superman her demise came about when she
picked up green kryptonite not knowing
the danger it represented after being
exposed to its radiation for too long
she's had come to it's fatal effects
making her way back to Jimmy Olsen she
asked him to wish her out of existence
something he agrees to do and so
following this story fan reaction to the
concept of Supergirl was overwhelmingly
positive with thousands of letters
pouring into the head offices of DC
Comics as a result Kara zor-el the most
well known version of Supergirl made her
appearance in the pages of Action Comics
issue number 252 and was created once
again by Otto bender providing a true
backstory for the character this time
Otto bender established that Kara zor-el
survived the explosion of Krypton along
with her father and her mother and
several others as a result of Krypton's
explosion the chunk of rock they were
living on had become an irradiated chunk
of Kryptonite placing a layer of lead on
the ground to keep themselves protected
a meteor shower composed of a radiated
chunks of Krypton took place and
polluted the atmosphere with the effects
of green kryptonite
seeing no option besides sending their
daughter away in an effort to save her
life
kara and her mother searched the cosmos
eventually locating earth realizing the
Superman had been sent to that planet
and had been endowed with super powers
after his arrival Kara's parents chose
that location and using a rocket ship
similar to the ship Superman arrived in
kara was sent to earth where she
encountered the Man of Steel was
enrolled in an orphanage and adopted the
mantle of Supergirl remaining hidden
from the world until Action Comics issue
number 285 when she was publicly
revealed by Superman and so with their
newest creation in hand
Supergirl was rolled over into her own
series under adventure comics and
alongside Superboy and Krypto the
Superdog opened the door for a host of
new characters to be introduced into the
Superman family including comet the
superhorse
streaky the super cat and beppo the
super-monkey by 1962 fans were beginning
to notice a trend with Mort Weisinger
operating as the sole editor of all
Superman titles an Emmy to add something
new to the superman landscape every six
months in addition to trying to separate
Silver Age Superman from his Golden Age
version almost all continuity prior to
his introduction as editor in 1957 was
either being completely ignored or
rewritten in 1960 with adventure comics
issue number 271 at the direction of
Weisinger Jerry Siegel who had since
returned to writing for DC established
that the hatred between Lex Luthor and
Superman dates back to the Man of
Steel's years as Superboy when he met
Lex Luthor as a teenager as a fan of
Superboy and looking to become the
world's greatest scientist Luthor had
developed an antidote to kryptonite but
when a fire broke out
Superboy used his breath to put it out
and destroyed Luthor's experiment in the
process losing his hair and blaming
Superboy by claiming that he was jealous
of Lex Luthor's intelligence the
animosity formed by Luthor towards
Superboy was used to explain his early
appearances in Superman comics and why
he had such a hatred for the hero while
some of these changes angered some fans
and that their favorite stories from the
time between the Silver Age and the
Golden Age were being ignored in the end
it served the purpose of creating a more
tight-knit continuity that allowed for
existing readers to pick up Superboy
titles read about an encounter and pick
up with his fruition in the Superman
titles or one of us related books with
this benefited existing fans and also
began to create a web of nightmares for
potential fans with the introduction of
the DC Multiverse in 1961 and the
crossovers that came with it individuals
looking to get into Superman comics were
met with a massive interweaving of
stories that began in one comic and he
concluded over the course of several
others as a result the
potential fans found themselves
frustrated and in turn began to take
notice of a competitor who was
introducing heroes that didn't gain
their abilities from a yellow Sun but
from the effects of cosmic rays
by 1962 Marvel Comics had introduced the
Fantastic Four as a response to DC's
Justice League of America led by the now
infamous duo with Stan Lee and Jack
Kirby the Fantastic Four shot that
company to instant success which was
then capitalized on with the
introduction of spider-man B Incredible
Hulk and the Avengers forced to share
the limelight with their newest
competitor DC had to find ways to make
Superman more accessible and fast where
they stood to lose their position as the
top company and the world of comic books
to this end in 1962 under Edmund
Hamilton actually comics number 293 saw
the return of red kryptonite previously
introduced in adventure comics number
252 in 1958 over the course of various
comics red kryptonite was established to
effect Superman a random ways with no
two samples working the same way making
us return in Action Comics number 293
Eman Hamilton used this to launch a
story titled a feud between Clark Kent
and Superman which saw a sample of red
kryptonite splitting the Man of Steel
into two distinct personalities
the heroic Clark Kent and the villainous
Superman and 1964 with Justice League
issue number 29 DC introduced earth
three a universe that existed opposite
of the earth one continuity which saw
the first appearance of the crime
syndicate a group consisting of evil
versions of DC's characters with this
version of Superman called Ultraman try
as they might while these stories were
aimed at maintaining existing readership
while bringing in new readers it only
served to complicate the Superman
landscape and so by 1970 mortal eye
singer had retired from DC after a
30-year career and was replaced by
Julius Schwartz the man instrumental and
the success of the Silver Age under
Julius Schwartz were Weisinger had a
more grandiose view of Superman Schwartz
wanted a more team down version that
returned to his golden age roots to
achieve this the various Superman titles
were split up with editor emails and
Bridwell
taking over Lois Lane girlfriend of
Superman Mike Schakowsky taking over
adventure comics and Murray Bolton off
taking over action comics Superman's pal
Jimmy Olsen and Superboy living Julius
Schwartz in charge of Superman proper
and world's finest a line of comics
featuring team-ups between Batman and
the Man of Steel believing that Superman
had become too powerful and unrelatable
during the era of Weisinger and that the
landscape had become too convoluted
Julius Schwartz brought and Dennis
O'Neil who had been riding the green
arrow and Wonder Woman titles and
alongside the affirmation editors cut a
swath through the Man of Steel's
continuity by eliminating the element of
Kryptonite which sports believed had
become an overused plot device
cancelling the imaginary stories line
which started as a series of
publications outside of the existing
Superman continuity and world Lois Lane
girlfriend of Superman and Superman's
pal Jimmy Olsen titles into Superman
family which served as an anthology for
the previously mentioned comics among
others in addition to this Julius
Schwartz killed off the villains mr.
Mixel pick bizarro and Titano as well as
Krypto the dog arguably the most famous
animal in DC Comics with comics like
1971 Superman number 233 and is shooting
the sandman saga which saw Superman's
power reduced as well as his return to
fighting villains on earth for majority
of his issues because fans were riding
in by the droves requesting a return to
cosmic adventures and the threats that
came with him by the time the Sandman
saga concluded with Superman issue
number 242 in 1971 DC cancelled the new
Superman line
and replaced both Julius Schwartz and
Dennis O'Neil with Cary Bates however
the damage had been done and following
the Schwartz eras conclusion in 1972
were some viewed that the age of
Superman was over and of the Man of
Steel was rapidly shrinking into
oblivion DC had a plan to not only
return Superman to relevance but to
shake pop culture to its core with a
story that would change comic books
forever